Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Were we required to characterise this age of ours by any single epithet, we should be tempted to call it the mechanical age, the age of machinery. Nothing is now done directly or by hand, all is by rule and calculated contrivance. For the simplest operation, some helps and accompaniments, some cunning, abbreviating process is in readiness. On every hand, the living artisan is driven from his workshop
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。要想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。如果我们必须用一个词来概括我们这个时代，我们很可能会称它为机械时代，即机器的时代。现在没有什么事情是直接用手工完成的，一切都循规蹈矩，通过精算的巧思来完成。对于最简单的操作，总有一些辅助和伴随手段，一些巧妙、简化的流程随时准备着。到处都有活生生的工匠被赶出车间
to make room for a speedier inanimate one. The shuttle drops from the fingers of the weaver and falls into iron fingers that ply it faster. Now that was the 19th century historian Thomas Carlyle writing in 1829. Tom Holland, the Industrial Revolution, even for somebody who spends all his time thinking about Christianity and the classical world, this is a pretty seismic subject, isn't it? Do you not think it's kind of the biggest?
给速度更快的无生命工匠腾出空间。织梭从织工的手指间滑落，掉进飞速运作的铁质手指中。这是19世纪历史学家托马斯·卡莱尔在1829年写下的文字。汤姆·霍兰，工业革命，即使对于一个整天思考基督教和古典世界的人来说，这也是一个相当震撼的主题，对吧？你不觉得这是最大的一场变革吗？
I mean, I think it's certainly the biggest topic that we've covered so far which is why we're going to try and do it in 50 minutes but i mean in terms of the of its impact on us on the planets on the on us and on the planet and actually it's interesting because i remember uh 10 years ago listening to an in our time on the industrial revolution it was a two parter and the reason that i remember it is that um melvin bragg got into a tremendous row with one of the contributors and basically it was about whether the industrial revolution was was due to kind of vast impersonal forces or whether it was due to um great men inventing things the genius of the english inventor no but specifically the genius of northern working class people like Melvin Bragg. And he was very cross at any implication that it hadn't been down to them.
我的意思是，我认为这绝对是我们迄今为止涵盖的最大主题，这就是为什么我们要尝试在50分钟内讲完它。但从它对我们、对地球、对我们的影响来看，其实这很有趣，因为我记得大约10年前，听过BBC《我们的时代》节目关于工业革命的节目，它分为两部分。我之所以记住它，是因为梅尔文·布拉格与其中一位撰稿人发生了激烈的争执，基本上争论的内容是，工业革命究竟是因为那种庞大、非个人的力量，还是因为伟大的人物发明了东西，是英国发明家的天才，不，具体来说是像梅尔文·布拉格那样的北方工人阶级的成就能代表的天才。而且他对任何暗示这并非归功于他们的说法都感到非常生气。
And at one point was smashing, bringing his face down on the table and shouting rubbish. We should do more of that in our own podcast. It's a fantastic listen. And I listened to it again last night in preparation for this. And it was just as entertaining as i remembered but the thing that struck me was that there wasn't a mention of of global warming or um yeah the kind of environmental impact of the industrial revolution so i think that that within the past decade our sense of how important the industrial revolution is has sped up so i'm very very very excited about having someone who can answer that question you know are we right in thinking that the industrial revolution probably since the agrarian revolution is the single
有一次甚至气得把脸砸在桌子上大喊一桩胡扯。我们应该在自己的播客里多做点这种事。这是一场精彩绝伦的节目。昨晚为了做准备，我又听了一遍。它依然像我记忆中那样引人入胜，但让我震惊的是，节目中竟然完全没有提到全球变暖，或者说工业革命带来的那种环境影响。所以我觉得，在过去的十年里，我们对工业革命有多么重要的认识已经加快了速度。因此，我非常非常兴奋能请到一位能够回答这个问题的人——你知道，我们认为工业革命可能自农业革命以来是单一的
biggest event in human history do we have someone who can answer that question we need we need a top top we've had top historians before we need a top top historian so we need somebody who's professor of modern british history at uea who is editor of the historical journal who is the president of the royal historical so basically it doesn't get topper than that that of the historical journal who is the president of the royal historical so basically it doesn't get topper than that that's the no somebody who's won history and we have that person it's Emma Griffin Emma Griffin you are the victor of history welcome to the podcast hello so Tom you have a question don't you well I do basically it's it's a reformulation of the question that I was just asking I think it's Vessi Dutrois.
人类历史上最大事件，这种看法对吗？我们有能回答这个问题的人吗？我们需要一个顶级的、真正顶级的——我们以前请过顶级历史学家，但这次我们需要一个顶级中的顶级历史学家——所以我们需要一位东安格利亚大学的现代英国史教授、《历史学期刊》的主编、皇家历史学会的主席。简而言之，没有比这更顶级的了！……那就是《历史学期刊》的……是皇家历史学会的主席，所以简而言之，没有比这更顶级的了！那就是不，是一个赢得过历史奖项的人。我们有这样的人，她就是埃玛·格里芬！埃玛·格里芬，你是历史的胜者，欢迎来到本期播客！你好。那么，汤姆，你有个问题，对吧？是的，基本上它是对刚才我问的问题的一个重新表述。我想那是韦西·迪特鲁瓦。
Dutrois. Dutrois. And he is quoting Hobsbawm, who said the Industrial Revolution was probably the most important event in world history. Was he right, Emma? Is he right? Well, I mean, I think all historians are going to try and make some big claims about the particular corner of the past that they study and claim it to be extremely important um is the i mean i think the industrial revolution is phenomenally important um and i do think it's i i think i'm like a lot of what any historian is looking at um you can you can truly say the industrial revolution is a turning point in human history it's it's even a
迪特鲁瓦。迪特鲁瓦。他引用了霍布斯鲍姆的话，霍布斯鲍姆曾说工业革命可能是世界历史上最重要的事件。他说得对吗，埃玛？他说得对吗？嗯，我的意思是，我想所有历史学家都会试图对他们所研究的过去的那一个特定角落做出一些宏大的声明，并宣称它极其重要。我的意思是，我认为工业革命具有现象级的重大意义。而且我确实认为，就像任何历史学家所研究的很多事物一样，你可以真正地说，工业革命是人类历史上的一个转折点，它甚至是一个
turning point um as you're saying i mean and that's enough i mean a turning point in human history. It's even a turning point, as you're saying, I mean, that's enough! I mean, a turning point in human, a genuine turning point in human history is amazing. It also is a turning point in planetary history, I think we're now understanding that in terms of the Earth it's also a turning point. I think it is the most important, you know, it's a huge significance. Why is it a huge significance before the industrial revolution most people in agricultural societies and let's not think about hunter-gatherer societies you've already mentioned there's the you know the switch to agriculture which is um you know the one
转折点，正如你所说，我的意思是，这就够了！我的意思是，人类历史上的一个转折点，一个真正的人类历史转折点，这太了不起了。它同时也是地球历史上的一个转折点，我想我们现在从地球的角度来看，也正在理解这一点，它同样是一个转折点。我认为这是最重要的一次，你知道的，它具有极其深远的意义。为什么它具有极其深远的意义？在工业革命之前，大多数人都生活在农业社会中——咱们先别去想狩猎采集社会，你刚才已经提到了向农业的转变，你知道，那是
that's prior i mean nobody goes from hunter-gathering to industrial revolution so let's just compare ourselves with these agricultural societies that existed previous to the industrial revolution everybody's poor you have a few really rich people it doesn't matter whether you're looking at a rich state like uh you know renaissance italy or you're looking at the greeks the romans these hugely successful empires or if you're looking at a much less um developed nation even in these richest of pre-industrial nations, most people are poor. You have a few very rich people and everybody else has one set of clothes,
发生在更早之前的转变。我的意思是，没有人会直接从狩猎采集跨越到工业革命，所以我们就把我们自己与工业革命之前存在的这些农业社会进行一个对比。每个人都很穷。只有少数非常富有的人。无论你看的是像文艺复兴时期的意大利这样的富裕国家，还是希腊人、罗马人这些极其成功的帝国，或者你看的是一个远没有那么发达的国家，即使在这些最富有的前工业化国家中，大多数人也都是穷人。只有少数非常富有的人，而其他所有人
one pair of shoes, if they have any shoes, a lot of people won't have shoes, obviously, one set of clothes and a constant anxiety and struggle to put enough food on the table for everybody in the household. That is what changes when we have industrial revolutions. We go from situations of plentitude, which doesn't mean that every person, every household in every industrial nation has abundant food, because we know things like food banks exist and we know
都只有一套衣服，一双鞋（如果有鞋的话，很多人显然连鞋都没有），只有一套衣服，并且为了让家里每个人都能吃饱饭而陷入持续的焦虑和挣扎中。这就是当我们经历工业革命时所改变的东西。我们从物资匮乏的境地中走出来——这并不是说每一个工业国家的每一个家庭都有充足的食物，因为我们知道食物银行这样的东西存在，我们也知道
there's a problem in getting food to people who need it, but as societies and as nations we do have abundance, we have switched this situation that humans have known since the beginning of time of scarcity and moved to one of abundance and plenitude and that's really a phenomenal change and one that's really worth talking about so if we go back to the absolute basics um i mean one of the weird things with industrial revolution is it seems so vague and such a sort of amorphous process. When does it start, would you say? What's the... 1700, 1600? You know, what's the kickoff?
在把食物送到需要的人手中方面确实存在问题，但作为一个社会和国家，我们确实拥有了丰裕的物质。我们已经改变了人类自古以来就经历的物资短缺的状况，转向了一个物资充裕和丰饶的时代。这真的是一个巨大的改变，非常值得我们去讨论。因此，如果我们回到最基础的层面，我的意思是，工业革命最奇怪的事情之一就是它看起来如此模糊，如此像一个无定形的过程。你认为它是什么时候开始的？起点是什么……1700年，1600年？你知道，它的发端是什么？
That's brilliant. So, OK, so we've got this big shift in our human existence from this kind of experience of scarcity to an experience of more abundance. When does it happen? Well, it's not one of those revolutions that happens on the 27th of january in a particular year it's a very different kind of revolution that takes a long time to happen it starts in britain um so we can we can we can pinpoint it on the globe in a particular place it spreads out from britain out to other parts of Europe, to North America, Australia.
太棒了。好吧，所以我们的整个人类生存状态发生了巨大的转变，从这种匮乏的体验转变为更加丰裕的体验。这究竟是什么时候发生的呢？嗯，它不是那种发生在某个特定年份1月27日的革命，它是一种非常不同的、需要很长时间才能发生的革命。它起源于英国，所以我们可以把它的全球坐标定位在某个特定的地方。它从英国向外扩散，传到了欧洲的其他地方、北美、澳大利亚。
I mean, that is still accepted, is it? That Britain is the home of the Industrial Revolution? Because I know that revisionism claims every aspect of history. Is there any kind of move to say, well, actually, it's not really Britain? No, I think everyone's happy to accept that it starts not only in europe but that it actually does start in britain and that hasn't been revised i think what where the revisionism comes in is is is people saying um at that moment it could have been another part of the world that did industrialize there's always been this hypothetical
我的意思是，这种观点现在仍然被普遍接受吗？即英国是工业革命的发源地？因为我知道修正主义会企图解构历史的每一个方面。有没有人试图去说，嗯，实际上，这并不是英国？不，我认为大家都乐于接受它不仅发源于欧洲，而且确实发源于英国，这一点并没有被修正。我认为修正主义介入的地方在于，人们开始说，在那个时刻，世界上其他地方也完全有可能走向工业化。一直以来都有这样一种假设性的
counterfact it could have been china could it could it have been could it have been china do you think well i think um it was rather unlikely to have been china because Could it have been? Could it have been China, do you think? Well, I think it was rather unlikely to have been China because I think actually Britain was different from other parts of Europe and certainly different from other parts of the world. So in terms of revisionism, I'm going to say no. I don't think there are many people claiming today that the Industrial Revolution might have happened, that the Industrial Revolution did actually happen somewhere else first.
反事实推论：会不会是中国？有没有可能是中国？你觉得有没有可能？嗯，我觉得，它不太可能是中国，因为……有没有可能？你觉得有没有可能是中国？嗯，我觉得它不太可能是中国，因为我认为实际上英国与欧洲其他地区不同，当然也与世界上其他地区不同。所以就修正主义而言，我想说“不”。我认为今天没有多少人会宣称，工业革命可能发生过，或者工业革命实际上是在其他某个地方首先发生的。
I think everyone is happy to accept that. The debates are that it might have happened somewhere else. And we can come back to those if you like, Tom. I'm not entirely convinced that it could have happened somewhere else. But it's only a might have, not a it actually did. So we're looking at Britain when does it start I mean I think we're looking at the um by the very end of the 18th century it's clear that things in Britain Britain is developing and the economy is operating in slightly different ways to its European neighbors um so that's kind of there are clear signs by the end of the century by the 1820s and by the 1830s I think it's very clear that the British economy is operating in a different way. So I'd kind of, I'd want to put it somewhere between the late 18th and the early 19th century.
我想大家都乐于接受这一点。争议在于它当时有没有可能发生在其他地方。如果你愿意的话，汤姆，我们可以回过头来探讨这些。我并不完全相信它当时可能发生在其他地方。但这只是一种可能性，而不是它真的发生过。所以我们把目光投向英国。它是什么时候开始的？我的意思是，我认为我们看到，到了18世纪的极末期，很明显英国的事物正在发展，经济的运行方式与其欧洲邻国略有不同。所以，到了那个世纪末，这种迹象已经很明显了。到了1820年代和1830年代，我认为很明显英国经济正以一种截然不同的方式运行。所以我会倾向于把它放在18世纪末到19世纪初之间的某个时间点。
But it has very long routes. You've gone later than I was expecting. I thought you would say 1700 or even earlier, actually. Well, it depends what you think the Industrial Revolution is. So for me, the Industrial Revolution is, I mean, well, let's start with the pre-industrial societies how do they work well everybody needs something to eat so you you grow your food in addition we all need stuff particularly in the northern northern cold climates we need clothes we need shoes we need buildings we want bits of transport to get us around and about we want to ride horses so we
但它的根源非常深远。你的时间比我预期的要晚。实际上，我原以为你会说是1700年甚至更早。嗯，这取决于你认为工业革命究竟是什么。所以对我来说，工业革命是——好吧，让我们从前工业化社会开始，它们是如何运作的？嗯，每个人都需要吃的东西，所以你要种植食物。此外，我们所有人都需要物品，特别是在寒冷的北方气候下，我们需要衣服、鞋子、建筑物，我们想要交通工具来四处奔波，我们想要骑马，所以我们
need saddles so we want the stuff as well and so it's that manufacturing is where the industrial revolution happens it's on making the stuff rather than on the food um but that stuff all the other things that also actually has to come out of the ground so if it if you want to wear a leather pair of shoes that's agriculture because you need you know get your leather off the animal skins if you want to wear woolen clothes that's sheep but you're getting your clothes off if you want to wear um any other kind of clothes linen linen is grown cotton is grown they're all exactly it all comes out of the soil so your buildings that's all comes out of wood that you've chopped down. Your fuel, that all comes from, again, the woods that you need, that you need to maintain woodland. So everything, everything comes back to the soil.
需要马鞍。所以我们也想要这些物品。因此，制造业就是工业革命发生的地方，它侧重于制造物品而不是食物。但是这些物品，以及所有其他的东西，实际上也都必须从土地里产出。所以如果你想穿一双皮鞋，那属于农业，因为你需要从动物皮毛上获取皮革；如果你想穿羊毛衣物，那是绵羊，你从羊身上获取衣物；如果你想穿任何其他类型的衣服，亚麻是种植出来的，棉花是种植出来的，它们完全都是，所有的东西都来自土壤。你的建筑物，这全部来自于你砍伐的木材。你的燃料，这也同样来自于你需要维持的林木。所以一切，一切都回归到土壤。
Everything comes back to the earth. And that's why everyone's poor, because there's never enough good things coming out of your local environment for everybody to be rich and have this life of plenitude so it's when we start to do things differently and we start to use other people's resources so cotton from all other parts of the world and we start to use things like coal and steam engines so we're no longer dependent on wood we can just shove coal in later in the society in the century people are using electricity from all sorts of different ways is when you start to kind of become far less dependent on your local environment and when you have these these kind of much more complex economies um with much bigger tentacles that stretch across the globe and you can use other people's resources for me that's what the industrial revolution is about
一切都回归到地球。这就是为什么每个人都很穷，因为从你当地的环境中永远产出不出足够的好东西，让每个人都能富有并过上这种物资丰裕的生活。所以，当我们开始用不同的方式做事，开始使用其他人的资源——比如来自世界其他地方的棉花，并开始使用煤炭和蒸汽机之类的东西（这样我们不再依赖木材，我们可以直接把煤炭扔进炉子里；在这个世纪的晚些时候，人们开始以各种不同的方式使用电力）——这时，你才开始在很大程度上不再依赖你当地的环境，当你拥有了这些更加复杂的经济体，它们的触角伸向全球各地，并且你可以使用其他人的资源时，对我和工业革命而言，这就是工业革命的意义所在。
that is all kind of happening around the 19th century. So, I mean, I'm sure this must be a naive question, but if that's the case, why does it not happen earlier? Why, for instance, does the Roman Empire not industrialise or the Chinese Empire? I mean, these are entities that have very, very kind of long tentacles. Why? I mean, is this a kind of inevitable process? Is it luck? What is it that lights the spark? Right. Well, that's it. So obviously, there have been other rich nations in the past, but they're still basically doing the same thing as I'm describing pre-industrial societies mostly do. do almost everything that is consumed or used comes out of the local environment in some way
这一切大概都发生在19世纪前后。所以，我的意思是，这一定是个很幼稚的问题，但既然如此，为什么它没有更早发生呢？比如，为什么罗马帝国或中国帝国没有工业化？我的意思是，这些实体都拥有非常、非常漫长的触角。为什么？我的意思是，这是一个不可避免的过程吗？是运气吗？究竟是什么点燃了火花？没错。就是这样。所以很明显，过去也有过其他富裕的国家，但它们基本上仍然在做我刚才所描述的前工业化社会通常在做的事情。它们几乎所有消费或使用的东西，某种程度上都产自当地环境
probably because transport just even if you've got an empire you can't afford to get stuff from one part of the world to another using these primitive transport techniques so you're kind of dependent on your own little part of the world um and having an empire being rich doesn't necessarily change any of that so what's going on in brit And again, it probably comes back to the China question as well. Why was it in Britain rather than in China or somewhere else? Because Britain all through the 18th century is working really, really, really hard to do things differently, to make a little bit more money. It's a very commercial nation. It's a very commercial nation um it's a it's a very commercialized nation already
这大概是因为交通运输……即使你拥有一个帝国，使用这些原始的交通技术，你也无法负担得起把东西从世界的一个角落运到另一个角落的成本，所以你某种程度上只能依赖你自己的那一小片世界。而且，拥有一个帝国、变得富有，并不必然改变这一切。那么英国究竟发生了什么呢？而且，这可能又回到了关于中国的问题。为什么是在英国，而不是在中国或其他什么地方？因为整个18世纪的英国，都在非常、非常、非常努力地用不同的方式做事，以赚取更多的钱。这是一个高度商业化的国家。这是一个高度商业化的国家，
and so people are no longer we've moved a very long way away from a peasant society where most people have their little plot of land and they're literally growing and producing everything i mean you know in other parts of europe at this point people are growing the flax that will make their clothes so they're not just growing their own agriculture they're growing what they're going to dress themselves in and all their fuel is coming from their own local plot of land so this is not the case in England at this point we've got away from that kind of peasant manufacture that kind of everybody with their little plot producing what they need for the next winter the next 12 months kind of scenario and we've got people with much larger farms
所以人们不再——我们已经离农民社会非常遥远了，在农民社会里，大多数人都有自己的一小块土地，字面意义上种植和生产一切。我的意思是，你知道，在欧洲的其他地方，此时人们还在种植用来做衣服的亚麻，所以他们不仅在种植自己的农产品，还在种植他们穿的衣服，并且他们所有的燃料都来自于他们自己的那一小块土地。但在此时的英国情况并非如此，我们已经摆脱了那种农民式的制造方式，摆脱了那种每个人都守着自己的一小块土地、生产自己接下来一个冬天或未来12个月所需物资的场景，我们拥有了更大的农场
they employ lots of workers the tasks have all been subdivided and Britain has got an empire it's pulling lots of raw resources raw materials in from other parts of the world it's got good woolen industry we don't have enough wool so it's importing lots of wool we're importing lots of flax and hemp because we want to produce linens but we don't grow enough material for that we're starting to import lots of cotton that's one of the big stories importing more and more cotton so it's already a very sophisticated it's a very sophisticated economy for what is still a traditional economy it's very sophisticated economy and it's it's traveled a long distance away from the kind of peasant origins of agricultural societies so we had a couple some questions from listeners about the origins of the industrial revolution so
它们雇佣了大量的工人，所有的任务都被细分了。而且英国拥有一个帝国，它正从世界其他地方源源不断地把大量的自然资源、原材料拉进国内。它拥有很好的毛纺工业，但我们的羊毛不够，所以它在进口大量的羊毛；我们在进口大量的亚麻和大麻，因为我们想要生产亚麻布，但我们种植的原料不够；我们开始进口大量的棉花，这是最大的故事之一，进口越来越多的棉花。所以它已经是一个非常复杂的经济体了，对于一个仍然保持传统的经济体而言，它是一个非常复杂的经济体。它已经从农业社会的农民起源出发，走了很长的一段路。所以我们有几位听众提出了关于工业革命起源的问题，所以
um you mentioned the empire stephan jensen um friend of the show always asking questions asked uh too many questions on our watergate episodes according to be told off give him another one uh he's asked a question about concentration and scale um enabled by the empire i mean britain wasn't the only country with an empire i mean obviously spain had had a colossal empire tons of gold in the 16th century and had failed to industrialize. So what is it about, or is there anything about Britain's empire that makes it? Also, if I could just ask about the Netherlands, which is an even more sophisticated economy than Britain's.
嗯，你提到了帝国。斯特凡·延森，节目的老朋友，总是喜欢提问，他问了……据（别人）说他在我们关于水门事件的节目里问了太多问题，所以得批评他一下，再给他提个问题——他问了一个关于由帝国带来的集中化和规模化的问题。我的意思是，英国并不是唯一一个拥有帝国的国家，显然，西班牙在16世纪曾拥有过庞大无比的帝国，拥有成吨的黄金，但它却未能实现工业化。那么，究竟是什么原因，或者说英国的帝国有什么特别之处，使之成为可能？另外，如果我可以顺便问一下关于荷兰的问题，它的经济甚至比英国还要复杂。
Tom is obsessed with the Netherlands. That's a great name. Holland is obviously a fantastic name. So, I mean, that's what i'm really interested in is why does it happen in britain and not say in the netherlands which in the 17th century is a much more sophisticated economy is that you know and the spanish thing so so why does it not why is it not spain why is it not the netherlands why is it britain yes lovely all brilliant questions and hello stefan nice to, nice to get a question
汤姆对荷兰很着迷。这是一个很棒的名字。荷兰显然是一个非常棒的名字。所以，我的意思是，我真正感兴趣的是为什么这种现象发生在英国，而不是例如17世纪经济更加成熟的荷兰，你知道的，还有西班牙的问题，所以，为什么不，为什么不是西班牙，为什么不是荷兰，而是英国？是的，太好了，这些都是精彩的问题，你好，斯特凡，很高兴能接到一个问题
from you, I'm glad the Industrial Revolution interests you as much as other topics that have been discussed on the programme I think it's a really empires abound world history is full of empires it's not full of nations that have industrial revolutions
来自你，我很高兴工业革命能像节目中讨论过其他话题一样引起你的兴趣，我认为，帝国在世界上比比皆是，世界历史充满了帝国，但并不是所有充满帝国的国家都能经历工业革命
particularly the world's first industrial revolution so empires in and of themselves are not causes of the industrial revolution but the empire does play a really big role in why britain is able to industrialize and i think it comes back again in some ways it does also link back to the why not Netherlands you know why not um why not Portugal and Spain they had these huge empires I mean you know what was going on there well empires provide raw materials and they you can flow these raw materials from other parts of the world into your country and that's what they've always done and the the Portuguese and the Spanish did that and the Romans were doing that
尤其是世界上第一次工业革命。所以，帝国本身并不是工业革命的原因，但帝国在英国为什么能够实现工业革命方面确实发挥了非常巨大的作用，我觉得这在某些方面又回到了“为什么不是荷兰”的问题上，你知道的，为什么不，嗯，为什么不选葡萄牙和西班牙？它们拥有如此庞大的帝国，我的意思是，你知道那里的情况吗？嗯，帝国提供原材料，你可以把这些原材料从世界其他地方源源不断地输送到你的国家，而这正是他们一直在做的，葡萄牙人和西班牙人这么做过，罗马人也这么做过
and the Chinese have done that with empires as well. You can bring raw materials back into your nation and that's useful and that's enriching. But it's not what an industrial revolution is. An industrial revolution is when you have a completely different approach to raw materials and to the things that you want so it's not just having the raw materials that's going to be significant it's something that's
中国人在建立帝国时也这样做过。你可以把原材料带回你的国家，这很有用，也能带来财富。但这并不是工业革命。工业革命是指你对原材料和想要的东西采取了完全不同的处理方法，因此，仅仅拥有原材料是不够的，这其中有着
innate in Britain and something that's kind of internal indigenous to Britain in that Britain doesn't want to have gold so that people can build a country house and then go and retire into the country and live a life of luxury and nobility and idleness. The whole point of being rich and having these trading networks that Britain has got in the 18th century is to grow rich and to make more money and to invest and to grow. And not to retire from business, but to develop the business and to enrich, to just carry on this process. And that kind of is up and down the economy at all levels. Everybody's kind of working, most people are working for wages. The point is to earn a bit more and to just to accumulate money, accumulate wealth, accumulate capital. And that's not true of imperial nations necessarily. Some people simply accumulate because they then want to put it on display,
英国所特有的、并且可以说是英国内部及本土生根发芽的东西，那就是英国人并不只是想要黄金来建造乡村别墅，然后退隐到乡村去过一种奢侈、贵族化和闲散的生活。富有以及拥有英国在18世纪建立的这些贸易网络的全部意义在于变得更富裕、赚更多的钱、进行投资并不断发展。而不是从商业中隐退，而是去发展商业、丰富财富，让这个过程一直持续下去。这种精神贯穿于整个经济的各个层面。每个人都在工作，大多数人都在为赚取工资而工作。重点是多赚一点钱，然后不断积累金钱、积累财富、积累资本。这并不一定适用于所有帝国国家。有些人单纯积累财富只是为了将其摆出来展示，
not because they want to make it work. So I think that's part of the story. What's very interesting in the case of Britain is, I don't think it was having the empire that caused us to industrialise, but because we are this different kind of nation that wanted to make profit at all points through the 18th century, what we do with our empire is completely different. We don't just get gold and hoard it.
而不是为了让它发挥作用。所以我觉得这就是故事的一部分。在英国的案例中，非常有趣的是，我不认为拥有帝国是导致我们工业革命的原因，但正因为我们是这种不同类型的国家，在整个18世纪都想要在各个环节追求利润，所以我们对待帝国的做法完全不同。我们不只是获得黄金然后将其囤积起来。
We get cotton, which is just a raw plant. And we're importing masses of... It would be useless if you didn't have anything you could do with it. What the British are doing are importing that raw material and then manufacturing it and then selling it across the rest of the globe and making a really healthy profit. And that form of behaviour is very different to the Empire. So the Empire is massively useful for Britain.
我们获取棉花，这只是一种生植物。我们在进口大量的……如果你拿它毫无用处的话，这就毫无意义了。英国人所做的是进口这些原材料，然后进行加工制造，接着将其销往世界各地，并赚取非常可观的利润。这种行为模式与单纯的帝国截然不同。因此，帝国对英国来说极其有用。
It wasn't the cause. Britain turns around the idea of what you do with an empire and just uses it in a very different way. I would say that's how I see it. So you're sort of saying it comes back to, I mean, we had a couple of questions, for example, Etienne Caswell asks about government policy. Are you basically saying it's a question of political
它并不是原因。英国彻底改变了你对帝国的处理方式，并以一种截然不同的方式加以利用。我想这就是我眼中的情况。所以你的意思是它归结为，我的意思是，我们之前有几个问题，例如埃蒂安·卡斯韦尔（Etienne Caswell）询问了政府政策。你的意思是这基本上是一个政治
and cultural kind of climate that drives the... So that's quite old-fashioned, right? It's quite kind of, I don't want to say Weberian, but you're sort of saying... Well, it's Braggian. You're not going to... It's our top inventors. Stop citing our rival, Tom.
和文化氛围驱动的问题……所以这相当老派，对吧？有点像，我不想说这是韦伯式的，但你的意思是……好吧，这是布拉吉安式的。你不会去……是我们顶尖的发明家。汤姆，别再引用我们的竞争对手了。
That's not right. So are you saying it's kind of Protestant work ethic, polite and commercial people, that kind of stuff, basically? Well, that's an interesting way of thinking about it. I think it is political and cultural. I think Britain is culturally different and behaving in a culturally different way um i think that a lot of those arguments in the past about the protestant worth ethic and the polite and commercial people um i think a lot of those are very approving um of this particular ethic and very unquestioning and very uncritical
这不对。所以你是说这是一种新教工作伦理、彬彬有礼且充满商业精神的人群，基本上就是那种东西？嗯，这是一个有趣的思考方式。我认为这确实是政治和文化的。我认为英国在文化上是不同的，并且表现出一种截然不同的文化行为，嗯，我认为过去关于新教工作伦理和彬彬有礼的商业人群的很多论点，嗯，我认为其中很多都非常赞同这种特定的伦理，非常不加质疑、非常缺乏批判性
and historically taken as a natural good that if you were innovating and if you were profit-making, then you were on the side of progress in some kind of way and these are good things. And I think part of our understanding over the past decade or more with global warming and the kind of the environmental impacts is I don't think we've got such an easy and relaxed attitude now that industrialization is naturally a good thing. And therefore that the people who are driving forward are naturally heroes and benefactors and good people in some kind of way. I think we have much, I would, I probably have a much more ambivalent interpretation of whether this is a good or a bad thing.
并且在历史上被视为一种自然而然的好事，即如果你在创新，如果你在创造利润，那么你在某种程度上就是站在进步的一边，这些都是好事。我想我们在过去十年甚至更长时间里，随着全球变暖和各种环境影响的出现，我们对工业革命天然是一件好事这种观点已经没有过去那样轻松和随意的态度了。因此，那些推动工业革命向前发展的人，在某种程度上也并非天生就是英雄、恩人和好人。我想我们对于这究竟是一件好事还是一件坏事，会有更加、我可能会有更加矛盾的解释。
But I do think it is cultural. I do think, I mean, another alternative way of putting it is capitalism, is that we're a very capital, and again, I mean, do you think capitalism is a good thing or a bad thing? I mean, some people like it, some people don't. But we are very capital oriented, wage oriented, money oriented, accumulating. I mean, I don't know if these are good things or bad things, but we were doing more commercial money-making activity across the board than other parts of Europe at this time.
但我确实认为这是文化使然。我确实认为，另一种表述方式就是资本主义，我们是一个非常资本导向的，再次强调，我的意思是，你认为资本主义是件好事还是坏事？我的意思是，有些人喜欢它，有些人不喜欢。但我们在资本导向、工资导向、金钱导向和财富积累方面非常突出。我的意思是，我不知道这些是好事还是坏事，但与当时欧洲的其他地方相比，我们在全方位地进行更多的商业赚钱活动。
But Emma just just to go back to the netherlands because he's obsessed i told you i did fudge it i didn't answer you about the netherlands they are protestant they are a commercial people they have an empire with raw materials they're very keen on getting richer in reinvesting so why why do they not have the industrial i mean is it is it down to raw materials is it about coal they don't have coal yeah so is it is it basically is is is that the the key do you think okay so i i would yes yes so let's go back to the netherlands so it is something to do with i mean i guess the coal is like the empire um lots of people have coal
但是艾玛，回到荷兰的问题上，因为他对荷兰痴迷，我告诉过你我确实避重就轻了，我没有回答你关于荷兰的问题：他们是新教徒，他们是商业民族，他们拥有带有原材料的帝国，他们非常热衷于变得更富有并进行再投资，那么为什么，为什么他们没有发生工业革命？我的意思是，这归结于原材料吗？是因为煤炭吗？他们没有煤炭，对吧？所以，这基本上是关键所在吗？好吧，所以，是的，是的，所以让我们回到荷兰，所以这确实与……我的意思是，我猜煤炭就像帝国一样……很多人都有煤炭
having coal is not enough to give you an industrial revolution and in our own case the coal had always been there i mean it had literally been there for millions of years um so having coal and china has coal and india has coal and russia has coal other places have coal and they didn't industrialize at this time so um it's not the having of the coal i think that's important um what we're doing in britain at this particular time is trying to get the coal out of the ground which is technically really difficult so you need a fairly skilled workforce you need a capitalized economy you need people with deep pockets who can take risky investments. You need skilled workers who will put their lives at risk trying to do this. You need entrepreneurs.
仅仅拥有煤炭是不够的，它不足以引发工业革命，就我们自己的情况而言，煤炭一直都在那里，我的意思是它字面上已经存在了数百万年，所以拥有煤炭的中国有煤炭、印度有煤炭、俄罗斯有煤炭、其他地方也有煤炭，但他们当时并没有工业革命，所以，拥有煤炭并不是最重要的，我认为，我们在英国这个特定时期所做的是试图把煤炭从地下开采出来，这在技术上非常困难，因此你需要一支相当熟练的劳动力队伍，你需要一个资本化的经济，你需要那些财力雄厚、能够承担风险投资的人。你需要那些甘愿冒着生命危险去完成这项工作的熟练工人。你需要企业家。
You need inventors who will risk trying to come up with a new way of doing this. That's just to get the coal out of the ground. Then you've got to make the coal do something useful, which means inventing some kind of steam engine and making the steam engine do what you do. So there are these thousands and thousands and thousands of intermediate intermediary steps there's the coal over there we had it other people had it too what we also had was this additional thing this desire to make a profit which meant we worked really hard to do something useful with that coal so let's go back to the Netherlands what's going on in the Netherlands well they don't have the coal so it was always
你需要敢于冒险发明新方法的发明家。这仅仅是为了把煤炭从地下挖出来。然后你得让煤炭发挥实际作用，这意味着发明某种蒸汽机并让蒸汽机按你的意愿工作。因此，这里面有成千上万个中间步骤：煤炭就在那里，我们有它，别人也有它；但我们同时还拥有这种额外的东西——渴望获得利润的欲望，这意味着我们为了让这些煤炭发挥实用价值付出了极其艰辛的努力。所以让我们回到荷兰，荷兰发生了什么？好吧，他们没有煤炭，所以从一开始
going to be more of a challenge but I'm never entirely convinced by arguments that suggest you need this resource or that resource because the whole point is every prior to industrialization every economy is really working with the resources that it does have and if you're really ready to do things in a different way you'll usually there'll be something there I mean it doesn't hold it doesn't hold the netherlands back today the fact that it doesn't have any coal there are other routes there are other routes and if the netherlands had really been at that moment in the 17th century where it could have done things differently it would have done we would have had a completely different industrial revolution which didn't involve coal but involved something else instead.
这就注定是一个更大的挑战，但我从来不完全相信那种认为你需要这种资源或那种资源的论点，因为关键在于，在工业革命之前，每个经济体实际上都在利用它所拥有的资源，如果你真的准备好以不同的方式做事，通常都会有办法的。我的意思是，这并不阻碍，今天荷兰没有煤炭的事实并没有阻碍它，还有其他途径，还有其他途径。如果荷兰在17世纪那个能够采取不同做法的时刻真正做到了这一点，它就会这么做，我们就会迎来一场完全不依赖煤炭、而是涉及其他事物的、截然不同的工业革命。
They just didn't want it. They just didn't want it enough. Didn't want it enough. So actually going back to the Melvin Bragg point about, you know, great inventors and entrepreneurs and all that kind of thing. Actually thinking that we did an episode on Silicon Valley and I was thinking about you know Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs and all these kind of guys who were would those kind of cluster of people who were just into that kind of thing they were just it was what you did and I wonder was it was there something about Britain in the 18th century that people just like kind of tinkering with machines and I mean was it kind of for
他们只是不想要。他们只是不够想要。不够想要。所以实际上回到梅尔文·布拉格关于伟大的发明家、企业家以及诸如此类事情的观点。其实想到我们做过一集关于硅谷的节目，我就想到了史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克、史蒂夫·乔布斯和所有这些家伙，那些沉迷于这类事情的群体，他们只是……这就是你所做的事情，我在想，18世纪的英国是不是有什么特质，让人觉得他们只是喜欢摆弄机器，我的意思是，这是一种为了
the fun of it I think there i mean it's really interesting the question of invention is really interesting there definitely is a culture of tinkering with machines but when you look closely and i spend a lot of time looking closely at individuals although we've been talking really generally about this massive shift in world history and playing a tutor you know actually what i do most of the time is look at the lives of individuals one person here and one person there just really small scale when you look at the lives of people who are doing inventing for example yes they like tinkering um but tinkering is really expensive it's really expensive and steve jobs if he was still with us would i'm
好玩吗？我认为那里……我的意思是，这真的很有趣，关于发明的问题真的很有趣，这里确实存在一种摆弄机器的文化，但当你仔细观察时——我花了很多时间仔细观察个人，尽管我们一直在非常笼统地谈论世界历史上的这种巨大转变，扮演着导师的角色——实际上我大部分时间所做的是观察个人的生活，这里一个人，那里一个人，规模非常小。当你观察那些进行发明创造的人的生活时，是的，他们喜欢摆弄机器；但摆弄机器的成本非常高，成本真的很高。如果史蒂夫·乔布斯今天仍然和我们在一起，我相信他也会
sure say exactly the same thing you have to devote a huge part of your life to putting in a massive amount of time and effort to doing this thing that may not make you any profit and often doesn't make any profit for a really long time because even if you manage to crack it with your invention your invention is not going to work very well in the first instance and it's going to be really expensive and it's going to be much cheaper for most people to just carry on employing a secretary than it is to install a computer and i suppose also somebody might nick it somebody exactly to say nothing of the fact somebody might nick it i mean it just goes on and on and on and on and on. It's really expensive and there's no guarantee of reward. So some societies and places can support people mucking around with this kind of activity and some can't. A peasant economy cannot afford to have people upsetting themselves from the
说完全相同的话。你必须将生命中的大部分时间投入到大量的时间和精力中，去从事这件可能无法为你带来任何利润的事情，而且通常在很长一段时间内都无法带来任何利润，因为即使你设法通过发明取得了突破，你的发明在最初阶段也不会运作得很好，而且成本会非常高，对大多数人来说，继续雇佣一个秘书要比安装一台计算机便宜得多。我想还有可能有人会偷走它。有人会——完全同意——更不用说随时有人会偷走它了，我的意思是，这种风险没完没了、没完没了。成本极高，而且没有任何回报的保证。因此，有些社会和地方能够支持人们胡闹这类活动，而有些则不能。农民经济无法承担人们将自己从
labour market for a few years on end and not being economically productive i mean it just doesn't it just isn't it just can't sustain that kind of activity um and there's no investors even if you come up with a great idea there'll be no investor because investors don't want to invest money in risky um inventions because that's not how things are done in that part of you know in that particular community that society so where were we um i think you know what i'm saying yes yeah yes so do we have to have the scientific revolution first then do you think as well um yeah it's sort of so there's lots of things there's lots of things coming into it so certainly having a kind of educated but you know a relatively educated society a scientifically inclined society one that's interested in
劳动力市场中抽离几年、且在经济上不具生产力的后果，我的意思是，它根本承受不起这种活动，而且没有投资者。即使你想出了一个绝妙的主意，也不会有投资者，因为投资者不想把资金投资于高风险的发明，因为在那个地方、那个特定的社群或社会里，事情不是那样运作的。所以我们刚才讲到哪了……我想你知道我想表达的意思，是的，是的，所以我们必须先经历科学革命吗？你也是这么认为的吗？嗯，是的，这有点……所以这里有很多因素，有很多因素在起作用。当然，拥有一个受过教育的、但你知道的，相对受过教育的社会、一个倾向于科学的社会、一个对……感兴趣的社会
research and investment but you also just need a fairly rich society with money with cash flowing around you need a society where cash is present and people can earn relatively good wages maybe they could save a bit of money they can take some risks they can find some pals who also got a bit of money who's also willing to take some risks you just need a society which has some money around so i don't think it's i mean you you kind of seem to think i want to say something about um well let's well you don't let's think about the bragging idea of the kind of the noble entrepreneur um with the with the genius um i'm not really saying that's what it is i'm just saying uh we like luca we like the we like the
研究和投资的社会，但你也同样需要一个相当富裕的社会，一个有资金、有现金流通的社会。你需要一个现金充裕的社会，人们可以赚取相对较高的工资，也许他们可以存下一笔钱，可以承担一些风险，可以找到一些同样手里有点钱、也愿意承担风险的朋友。你只需要一个拥有一定资金的社会。所以我不认为……我的意思是，你好像觉得我想说点关于……好吧，让我们……你不想的话就算了，让我们想想关于那种带有天才光环的高贵企业家的布拉格式观点。我并不是真的认为这就是真相，我只是说，嗯，我们喜欢卢卡，我们喜欢……我们喜欢
money i mean i'm not saying this is good or bad this is just how it was yes you've got to have a certain degree of income to be able to that's how this podcast works how does the podcast work is it ingenuity is it genius just tom's desire for money that's all it is that's what drives it so emma just i i think we should have a break in a minute and come back and look at the kind of some of the individual lives, the lived experience, all that kind of thing, how life changed for people who lived through the Industrial Revolution. Can I just ask one further macro question, which is the role that's played by war, because the Industrial Revolution is coinciding with war between Britain and revolutionary France. And two questions really, does that have an impact on the industrialization of Britain? So I'm guessing the Royal Navy is a kind of a massive center for innovation. And the second question is,
金钱。我的意思是，我并不是说这是好事还是坏事，事情本来就是这样的。是的，你必须拥有一定程度的收入才能做到这一点……这个播客就是这样运作的。这个播客是怎么运作的？是靠机智？是靠天才？还是仅仅出于汤姆对金钱的渴望？仅此而已，这就是驱动它的动力。所以艾玛，我——我觉得我们一会儿应该休息一下，然后回来看看某些个人的生活、亲身经历以及所有类似的事情，看看那些经历过工业革命的人的生活发生了怎样的变化。我还可以问一个更宏观的问题吗？那就是战争所扮演的角色，因为工业革命恰逢英国与革命法国之间的战争。实际上有两个问题：这会对英国的工业化产生影响吗？所以我想皇家海军应该是创新的巨大中心。第二个问题是，
say had Britain lost, had the French occupied Britain, would that have cramped the process of the industrial revolution? So I think, think yeah there's a lot to unpack there sorry that's a very unfulfilled no i love it i love it i'm just thinking how can i how can i respond to this if we think about what industrialization is doing the part of it is is very i mean what's happening you're just outgrowing your own resources and
假设英国战败了，假设法国占领了英国，这会阻碍工业革命的进程吗？所以我想，是的，这里有很多东西需要剖析。抱歉，这是一个非常不成熟的……不，我喜欢，我喜欢。我只是在想，我该如何回应这个问题：如果我们思考工业革命在做什么，其中一部分是非常……我的意思是，发生了什么，你只是超越了你自己的资源极限，而
that's what's happening in britain and a lot of europe is outgrowing its own resources and that's what's happening in Britain and a lot of Europe is outgrowing its own resources it wants more stuff because if you're going to have factories and if you're going to make profit and you're you're going to have successful businesses you need lots of raw materials and these small we're with these all these nations in northern Europe we're very small geographically um there's just not a lot of resources and a lot of stuff to work with so you're going to need other people's stuff and that means uh you're probably going to get drawn into conflict in other parts of the world because a lot of what's going on through the um late 18th early 19th century is kind of struggle over trade routes and access to resources um so i think warfare is part of the story of industrialization it's hard to see how you could have had harmonious happy everybody just
英国和许多欧洲国家正在超越自身的资源支撑能力，这就是英国和很多欧洲国家正在发生的情况，它想要更多的东西，因为如果你要拥有工厂，如果你要赚取利润，如果你要经营成功的事业，你需要大量的原材料，而这些小的——我们在北欧的这些国家，从地理上看非常小，嗯，资源其实并不多，可以利用的东西也很有限，所以你需要别人的东西，这意味着呃，你很可能会被卷入世界其他地方的冲突中，因为在18世纪末到19世纪初期间，很多事情某种程度上都是围绕贸易路线和资源获取的斗争，嗯，所以我认为战争是工业化故事的一部分，很难想象怎么可能会有那种和谐快乐、每个人都只是
industrializes because everybody wants more stuff they want to take it from other people and there's going to be kind of lots of conflict and so we see that we see that building up the Navy. Well, that obviously is quite expensive in and of itself. I don't want to say there's no way that Britain could have lost the French Revolutionary Wars. It could have lost the Revolutionary Wars. happening in terms of the British government very astutely all through the 18th century taking a very active role in supporting British business by keeping an eye open on what's happening in other parts of the world and investing in the navy. Britain was the British economy was more developed in the 18th century by the end of the 18th century than the french economy was which was still mostly agricultural still had a lot of big pockets of mostly peasant farming and peasant agriculture and was just generally much less capitalized and much less money uh sloshing
走向工业化的过程，因为每个人都想要更多东西，他们想从别人那里拿走，这将会引发大量的冲突，所以我们看到这种情况，我们看到海军在不断建设。嗯，这本身显然相当昂贵。我并不是说英国绝不可能在法国大革命战争中失败。它完全可能在革命战争中失败。发生的实际情况是，英国政府在整个18世纪表现得非常精明，通过密切关注世界其他地方发生的事情并投资海军，非常积极地支持英国企业。在18世纪，英国经济比法国经济更发达，到了18世纪末更是如此，而法国经济仍然以农业为主，有大量主要由小农耕作和农民农业组成的板块，总体上资本化程度要低得多，流通的资金也少得多
around france and france is a bigger country it's got a bigger population which is why it can kind of partly why it can be successful in quite a lot of wars because it's got a lot of people um and that's that's really useful and and bigger bigger bigger populations tend to be richer before industrial revolutions and then of course that breaks down in modern societies so um what am i saying we're always going to win i can't win we weren't always going to win that's not quite what we're, but it's not entirely accidental that we win. It's not a fluke of history. It wasn't a turn of a dice. That's what I'm saying. There's a lot underneath these stories.
在法国到处流转，而且法国是一个更大的国家，人口更多，这也是它能够在相当多的战争中取得成功的部分原因，因为它拥有大量人口，嗯，这非常有用，而且在工业革命之前，人口规模更大的国家往往更富裕，当然，在现代社会中，这种规律就被打破了。所以，嗯，我是在说什么，我们总能赢吗？我不能说我们必胜，我们并非总是能赢，这并不是我所要表达的，但我们取胜也绝非全凭偶然。这不是历史的侥幸。这也不是掷骰子的结果。这就是我想说的。这些故事背后其实有很多深层原因。
And if you look more closely inside Britain and inside France in the late 18th century, you actually see very different kinds of economies, very different kinds of societies, ones that were going to be very helpful for Britain to streak ahead, both industrially and on the kind of the global power stage. And we're going to make it very hard for France to do that. This is great. OK, So there's been no... You haven't given Tom a chance to do his Melvin Bragg shouting, which is good.
如果你仔细观察18世纪末的英国和法国内部，你会发现它们实际上有着截然不同的经济形态，截然不同的社会类型，这些因素将极大地帮助英国在工业上以及全球权力舞台上脱颖而出，一路领先。并且会让法国很难做到这一点。这太棒了。好的。所以并没有……你没有给汤姆一个机会来大喊大叫他的墨尔本·布拉格式风格，这挺好的。
So we're going to take a break and then we'll come back and we'll go a bit granular and we'll talk about ordinary people and how the Industrial Revolution changed their lives. So see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
所以我们要休息一下，然后回来深入探讨细节，聊聊普通人以及工业革命是如何改变他们的生活的。休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《剩下的都是娱乐》
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告节目、获取加更剧集以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的轨迹》。
Time, I think, for a bit of Dickens. On every side and as far as the eye could see into the heavy distance, tall chimneys crowding on each other and presenting that endless repetition of the same dull ugly form which is the horror of oppressive dreams, poured out their plague of smoke, obscured the light and made foul the melancholy air. On mounds of ashes the strange engines spun and writhed like tortured creatures clanking their iron chains, shrieking in their rapid whirl as though in torment unendurable and making the ground tremble with their agonies.
我想，是时候读一点狄更斯的作品了。在四面八方，只要眼睛能看到的那片沉重而遥远的雾霭中，高耸的烟囱彼此拥挤在一起，呈现出那种单调、丑陋的千篇一律的形态，这正是压抑梦境中的恐怖所在，它们喷涌出毒烟般的废气，遮蔽了日光，将忧郁的空气污染得污浊不堪。在一堆堆灰烬上，奇特的机器像遭受酷刑的生物一样扭动盘旋，拖着冰冷的铁链发出刺耳的碰撞声，在飞速的旋转中发出尖叫，仿佛正经受着难以忍受的折磨，让大地在它们的痛苦中颤抖。
So that's Charles Dickens in the old curiosity shop in 1841. And shockingly, he's talking about the black country from which my forebears come. Very, very sad scenes to see in this. And mine too, Dominic. About the West Midlands. But that's why we speak in these kind of very strong kind of West Bromwich accents, isn't it, Tom?
那是查尔斯·狄更斯在1841年的小说《老古玩店》里的描写。令人震惊的是，他谈论的正是我的祖先所来自的黑乡地区。看到这些景象真的非常非常悲伤。我的也是，多米尼克。关于西米德兰兹郡。但这就是为什么我们操着这种非常浓厚的西布罗米奇口音说话的原因，对吧，汤姆？
Right, so Emma, Emma Griffin, top historian, the top historian, president of the Royal Historical Society, is with us talking about the Industrial Revolution. Emma, Eric Mercer has a question, and he says, was Dickens' portrayal of English society in the Industrial Revolution,
好，那么艾玛·格里芬，顶尖历史学家，皇家历史学会会长，今天和我们一起谈论工业革命。艾玛，埃里克·梅瑟有一个问题，他问，狄更斯对工业革命中英国社会的描绘——
specifically, I suppose, the poverty and the costs of the industrial revolution was it accurate and i suppose that goes to dickens to some extent has created our image certainly the 19th century as kind of extremes of wealth and poverty you know clanking machines chimneys misery urchins all this stuffness in the air soot yeah but is that but you said right at the beginning that it was the industrial revolution is about going from scarcity to plenitude so is the is the dickens view unfair would you say well lovely question eric and thank you very much for it what um what do i make of dickens and his interpretation of the industrial revolution okay so there's lots there's there's lots to say. I always have a lot to say, and I guess this is no exception.
具体来说，我想是指贫困以及工业革命的代价，它准确吗？我想这在某种程度上说明了狄更斯确实塑造了我们的形象，特别是19世纪那种财富与贫困的极端对比，你知道的，咔哒作响的机器、烟囱、苦难、流浪儿，空气中的各种脏东西、煤烟，是的。但这是——但你一开始就说过，工业革命是从稀缺走向丰裕的过程，那么狄更斯的观点是不公平的吗？你会这么认为吗？真是个好问题，埃里克，非常感谢你提出它。那么，呃，我对狄更斯及其对工业革命的解读有什么看法呢？好吧，这里有很多要说的。我总是有一大堆话要说，我想这次也不例外。
Let's think about some of the things that's going on there. Well, one of the depictions that Dickens gives us is of pollution and dirt and smoke and grime. I'm happy with that. I think that's right. These Victorian cities were dirty and smoky and dark in some respects. And what was our industrial revolution about? Our industrial revolution was all about coal. Coal is dirty, it is smoky.
让我们来思考一下其中发生的一些事情。嗯，狄更斯给我们的描绘之一就是污染、肮脏、烟雾和污垢。我对此没有异议。我认为这是对的。这些维多利亚时代的城市在某些方面确实是肮脏的、烟雾弥漫的、昏暗的。我们的工业革命是关于什么的？我们的工业革命完全是关于煤炭的。煤炭是脏的，也是烟雾腾腾的。
I think there's a lot of truth in that. And other nations, even when they industrialise with cleaner fuels, it always upsets the environment. There's always environmental damage. When you start producing much, much more stuff than you actually just need to keep you fed and clothed and shod, you're going to make a lot of mess. And that's kind of a feature of industrial industrialisations, industrial revolutions. So I'm happy with that. Take that from Dickens. What else? What he's saying, the other thing I think we get out of Dickens is this sense of loss, that it was kind of nice before it was clean and pleasant and it was nice I mean I
我认为这其中包含着很大的真实性。即使其他国家在利用更清洁的燃料进行工业化时，也总是会扰乱环境。总会有环境破坏。当你开始生产远超你仅用来维持温饱所需的物资时，你就会制造出大量的混乱。这也是工业化进程、工业革命的一个特征。所以我对此表示赞同。接受狄更斯的这一看法。还有什么？他所说的，我们从狄更斯身上得到的另一件事就是这种失落感，即在这一切之前，世界似乎很美好、很干净、很惬意，而且很美好，我是说——
think he he very much buys into like a lot of Victorian commentators buys into the fact that the modern world is difficult and dirty and hard and the old world was cleaner and purer and happier that I don't buy partly because I actually um pre-industrial life is really really really hard and that's never fully acknowledged it's really hard um it's back breaking work I mean none of us want to go back to living in that kind of world there's very little um intellectual um fulfillment or interest in that kind of for most people you have to go hungry a lot of the time you don't have shoes or your children certainly don't have shoes even if you manage to have shoes it's
我认为他非常赞同，就像许多维多利亚时代的评论员一样，他认同现代世界是困难的、肮脏的、艰辛的，而旧世界则更干净、更纯粹、更快乐，这一点我并不买账。部分原因是因为我实际上——前工业时代的生活真的非常非常艰辛，而这一点从未被充分承认。它真的很艰难，那是让人累断脊梁骨的体力活，我的意思是，我们谁都不想回到那种世界生活，那里几乎没有智力上的满足感或乐趣，对于大多数人来说，你大部分时间都得挨饿，你没有鞋穿，或者你的孩子肯定没有鞋穿，即便你能设法搞到鞋子，那也是
uncomfortable um it's cold in a place like this a lot so so i i don't buy i don't buy that it was nice and clean um before it was really difficult before and then it was difficult with the industrial revolution but it was a different kind of difficult um would you rather have been a peasant or a member of the proletariat exactly who has it better exactly so that's the question to ask and dickens isn't very well placed to ask ask or answer that question because he was neither peasant nor proletariat. Like almost all of the commentators who wrote about the experience of living during the Industrial Revolution that got published and who now form part of our kind of cultural understanding
很不舒服的，在一个像这样的地方经常很冷，所以——所以我不买账，我不认为在工业革命之前它是美好而干净的，以前的日子真的很艰难，然后工业革命之后也同样艰难，但那是另一种艰难。你宁愿当一个农民还是无产阶级的一员？完全正确，谁过得更好？没错，这就是需要提出的问题，而狄更斯并不具备很好的条件去提出或回答这个问题，因为他既不是农民，也不是无产阶级。就像几乎所有那些撰写关于在工业革命期间生活体验的文章、得以发表并最终构成了我们对该时期文化理解的评论员一样——
of the period, he was not actually a worker himself. I mean, I know he had his own case. He had experienced some child labour, but certainly he had experienced some child labour, but he's not exactly, he's not really, by the time he's writing his novels, he's, you know, and even as, I mean, the reasons for him experiencing the child labour were slightly unusual compared to those for the kind of the rank and file. Yeah, it's only because his dad's in debt, right? It's not because he's born into a family that are doing that all the time exactly slightly different story so um so
他实际上并不是一名工人。我的意思是，我知道他有他自己的特殊情况。他确实经历过一些童工劳动，但是当然他确实经历过一些童工劳动，但并不完全是这样，他其实并非——当他写小说的时候，他已经是（你知道的），甚至作为——我的意思是，他经历童工劳动的原因与那些普通大众相比有点不同。是的，那只是因为他爸爸负债了，对吧？并不是因为他生来就是一个世代从事那种劳动的家庭，完全不是，这是一个略有不同的故事。所以，嗯，所以——
that's the question to ask which was better well for me i think um i would strongly suggest that i think being a member of the politera is better than being um and we want peasants just to clarify as well the grandparents of children working and the adults working in the um factories in the 19th century hadn't been peasants they'd been agricultural laborers so they'd been workers children working and the adults working in the factories in the 19th century hadn't been peasants they'd been agricultural laborers so they'd been workers but they'd worked on somebody's farm instead of working in somebody's factory maybe the peasant life is better but we have to go in England we have to go hundreds of years back to find lots of peasants we just you had the choice
这就是需要问的问题：哪个更好？对我来说，我想，呃，我强烈地认为，作为一个无产阶级成员要比作为——并且为了澄清起见，我们指的是农民，在19世纪的工厂里工作的儿童和成年人的祖父母其实并不是农民，他们曾是农业工人。所以他们曾经是劳动者，孩子们在工厂工作，19世纪工厂里的成年人也不是农民，他们是农业工人的后代；所以他们一直是劳动力，只不过他们是在别人的农场干活，而不是在别人的工厂干活。也许农民的生活更好，但在英国，我们必须追溯到几百年前才能找到大量的农民，我们只是——你有这样的选择
of working for a farmer outdoors in the cold, in the rain, digging up fields and laying turnips is not thrilling work or going and working in the factory. And so those are your options. And when you look at the life stories, the autobiographies of men, mostly who have done one or the other, the answer is very, very clear. It's much better to go and work in the factory. And there are lots of reasons for that. Which is presumably why people go and do it. The evidence speaks for itself. People go and they don't tend to go back. They don't go, discover what it's like, and then head straight back as fast as they can.
为农夫在户外顶着寒风冷雨干活，在地里挖土、种植芜菁，这可不是什么激动人心的工作；或者去工厂打工。这就是摆在你面前的选择。当你查看那些曾从事过其中一种或另一种工作的男性的生平故事和自传时，答案非常非常明确。去工厂工作要好得多。这背后有很多原因。
They go and they stay. They go, they get higher wages. And a lot of people like earning more money. So there's the higher wages, which is a real draw. But it's not just the higher wages. I think that's not the real lure of urban life it's just life in the city is more varied it's more interesting it's got more opportunities um and having that bit of extra wage is quite empowering for the men who earn it so you can actually start to make decisions with your life you can decide to learn to read and write you can take yourself off to night school you can get involved in politics
这也是人们纷纷选择去那里工作的原因吧。事实胜于雄辩。人们去了之后往往就不会再回来了。他们不会去体验一下工厂生活，然后又以最快的速度逃回原先的地方。他们去了并留了下来。他们去那里拿到了更高的工资。很多人都喜欢赚更多的钱。所以更高的工资是一个真正的吸引力。但不仅仅是更高的工资。我认为这并不是城市生活真正的诱惑所在，只是城市生活更加丰富多彩，更加有趣，有更多的机会，而且手中多出的一点工资对于赚钱的男性来说具有相当大的赋能作用，因此你实际上可以开始为自己的生活做决定，你可以决定学习读写，你可以去上夜校，你可以参与政治
you can be a somebody in your community you can be a leader in the union you not everybody does this but you you have opportunities that are just not open to you when you are employed on the land emma you mentioned men there we've got a question from Flea how did the industrial revolution change women's lives did they gain more independence? I mentioned men because most of the sources that we have written about the industrial revolution have been written by men and I've looked at a lot of them and i think that story is quite clear and quite strong and it stands out you know it kind of it stands stands up to scrutiny we don't have women telling us what it was like for them so it's much harder to write that story and to be sensible there what do i
你可以在社区里成为一个有头有脸的人物，你可以成为工会的领导者。虽然不是每个人都这样做，但你拥有了在土地上雇工时根本无法获得的机遇。艾玛，你刚才提到了男性，我们有一个来自“跳蚤”（Flea）的问题：工业革命是如何改变女性的生活的？她们获得了更多的独立性吗？我之所以提到男性，是因为我们所拥有的关于工业革命的大多数书面资料都是由男性撰写的，我研究过其中的许多资料，我认为这个故事非常清晰、非常有说服力，它站得住脚（你知道的，它经得起推敲）。我们没有女性来告诉我们她们的经历是怎样的，所以要写好这个故事并做到客观要困难得多。我认为——
think going on well i think i used to be a bit more positive about how it impacted on women's lives because young women certainly do start working in the factories and if women are working in the factories they earn quite a good wage and that's quite empowering for them with respect to their family whether it's their parents or their siblings or their husband if they can earn a decent wage that is quite empowering for them however women sooner or later are likely to get married and to get pregnant. And then you've got the responsibility of raising children, which isn't something that you can do in this world where you haven't got electricity and you haven't got that much money and do a 12 or 14 hour day in the factory as well. So most women, even if they have this little window in their life where they have high wages and a bit of autonomy that comes with that, it is just a really small window. And then before long, they're back in the home and they're doing unpaid work.
我觉得情况是怎样的？嗯，我以前对它如何影响女性生活持更乐观的态度，因为年轻女性确实开始进入工厂工作，如果女性在工厂工作，她们能赚到相当不错的工资，这对于她们在家庭中的地位（无论是面对父母、兄弟姐妹还是丈夫）来说是一种相当大的赋能，如果她们能赚到可观的工资，这确实赋予了她们力量。然而，女性迟早都要结婚并怀孕。接着你就要承担抚养孩子的责任，在这个没有电、也没有那么多钱的世界里，你不可能一边抚养孩子，一边还要在工厂里干上12到14个小时的活。所以绝大多数女性，即便她们在生活中曾有过这样一小段窗口期，能够拿着高薪并随之获得一点点自主权，那也只是一段非常短暂的窗口期。随后不久，她们就会重返家庭，从事无偿劳动。
And there's nothing very liberating. Am I right in thinking that the process of industrialisation in the early stages destroys a lot of the work that women had in kind of cottage industries? I think it does destroy women's work, or it can do. I mean, it certainly is, you know, it's undermining women's work. But for me, I think it's more, it's not so much that it's undermining the work opportunities that are available for women, because the work opportunities that had been available i mean i would say the same about those as i would about the work that was available to men it was pretty rubbish really really long hours really low pay uh repetitive not particularly enjoyable not very empowering so i don't think it's the loss of those opportunities
并且这并没有什么特别解放的地方。我这样认为对吗：工业化进程在早期阶段摧毁了许多女性在某种家庭手工业中从事的工作？我认为它确实摧毁了女性的工作，或者说它完全可能做到这一点。我的意思是，这当然（你知道的）是在削弱女性的工作机会。但对我来说，我觉得更主要的不是它在削弱可供女性选择的工作机会，因为曾经可供选择的工作机会——我的意思是，我对那些工作的看法和我对当时男性可供选择的劳动的看法是一样的：它们真的挺烂的，工时极长、薪酬极低、重复枯燥、没有什么特别的乐趣，也谈不上什么赋能，所以我并不认为失去那些机会
you know i don't think they're devastating for women i mean okay so you could have spun at your wheel and made a little bit of money but it was pretty boring spinning at wheels and you didn't make a lot of money anyway so whatever what what is significant about those earlier households is the work that you did had value within the household and that gave you a little bit of a gave you some a space inside the family hierarchy it gives some importance inside the family and when we move to kind of the modern world where men go out and earn a good wage and quite a big wage and an improving wage then the work that women does becomes less value but becomes of less value within the household so for me that's really the switch that's happening more than the loss of work it's the lot of it's the loss of status inside the family let me ask you about a different group Emma that you talk about
（你知道的）对女性来说是毁灭性的打击。我的意思是，好吧，你可以在纺车上纺线赚一点微薄的钱，但踩纺车其实非常无聊，而且无论如何你也赚不到很多钱。所以，那些早期家庭生活的真正意义在于，你在家里面所做的工作在家庭内部是有价值的，这为你提供了一点点的空间，让你在家庭等级制度中占据一席之地，这赋予了你在家庭内部的重要性。而当我们转向那种现代世界时，男性外出赚取丰厚的工资、相当可观且不断增长的工资，那么女性所做的工作的价值就降低了，在家庭内部的价值变得微不足道了。所以对initializeApp我来说，这才是真正发生的转变，而不仅仅是失去了工作本身，更重要的是失去了在家庭内部的地位。让我问你关于另一个群体的问候，艾玛，你谈到了这个群体
in your because you've got your brilliant book Liberty's Dawn which is the sort of story of the industrial revolution through ordinary people who've written memoirs and things and you have a section in that if I remember right about children and am I right in thinking you say the industrial revolution was a disaster for children or something like that and you talk about people there's some story about a guy who's working you know 14 hour days on saturdays or something like i can't remember the exact details it's some i mean it is a brilliant book but i have to confess it is some years since i read it so children i mean they're the that that goes back to dickens it's the image we have in the industrial revolution
因为你写过那本精彩的书《自由的黎明》，那是通过写过回忆录等资料的普通人的视角来讲述工业革命的故事。如果我没记错的话，你在书里有一个关于儿童的章节。我的理解对吗，你说工业革命对儿童来说是一场灾难或类似的话？你提到过有人在星期六工作14个小时左右，诸如此类的事情——我记不清具体细节了。我的意思是，这是一本好书，但我得承认我已经有好几年没读过了。所以说到儿童，这可以追溯到狄更斯，这就是我们对工业革命的印象。
kids i mean horrible histories. When they sing their song about the whole of world history, they say kids in factories and down mines. That's a pretty big cost, isn't it? I mean, of the industrial... Pretty big downside? Yes. I know I'm very happy to...
孩子们，我是说《糟糕的历史》。当他们唱起关于整个人类世界历史的歌时，他们会唱到工厂里和矿井下的孩子们。这代价相当大，对吧？我是说，工业……一个相当大的负面影响？是的。我知道我非常乐意……
I'll give you the children. I'm not going to point you on the children okay i couldn't agree more um children tended not to work before the industrial revolution very much because there wasn't very much work around for them and children also tended to go hungry a lot because non-working people couldn't you know in many you know many parts of society couldn't really be fed properly either so there's a lot of child hunger there's a lot of extreme poverty and there's not much work so work is viewed as the solution out of the problem of raising children and it wasn't really available in rural England most of the time as much as people wanted it to factories come along great
我承认孩子们的问题。我不会在这点上反驳你，好吧，我非常赞同。嗯，在工业革命之前，孩子们往往不太需要工作，因为那时候周围没有什么工作可做。而且孩子们也常常挨饿，因为许多没有工作的人——你知道，在社会的许多阶层——也无法真正吃饱。所以当时有很多儿童挨饿的现象，有大量的极端贫困，而且工作岗位也不多。因此，工作被视为解决抚养儿童这一难题的出路。而且在英国农村，大多数时候并没有人们想要的那么多工作机会。工厂出现了，太好了，
you could put your children in the factory you You've got long hours, steady wages. And what these families are doing are feeding their children much better. I don't think I don't know which is better and which is worse. I mean, neither is good. Going hungry is not good. Working in factories is dreadful and is awful as well. I don't know. You know, so it's all bad. It's all really bad. But when it comes to it, the long hours in the factory seem to be, seem to me to be even worse than not having enough food,
你可以把你的孩子送进工厂。你有漫长的工作时间，稳定的工资。这些家庭在做的是让他们的孩子吃得更好。我不认为——我不知道哪个更好，哪个更糟。我是说，两者都不是好事。挨饿不是好事。在工厂工作也很糟糕，同样可怕。我不知道。你知道，所以这全都是坏事。这全都很糟糕。但归根结底，工厂里漫长的工作时间似乎——在我看来，甚至比没有足够的食物还要糟糕，
more damaging to a child's wellbeing, more damaging to their health, their wellbeing, their development in every single way. So I think this is an unmitigated disaster. I do think it's not a mitigated disaster for children the lesson from dickens is you need to find a benevolent patriarch don't you to kind of take you under his wing and yeah or a convict if you plumb like you got convicts to go to australia and leave you loads of money but it is i mean it is kind of guess telling that so many plots revolve around a hungry, starving child who then gets adopted by magic, taken into the kind of the world of the bourgeoisie. And I guess that the bourgeoisie are the other side of the coin. So presumably they are getting rich in a way. I mean, you know, I think even you look at your average
对儿童福祉的损害更大，对他们的健康、福祉以及方方面面的发展造成的损害更大。所以我认为这是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。我确实认为，对孩子们来说，这是一场不折不扣的灾难。从狄更斯那里得到的教训是，你需要找到一个仁慈的家长式人物，不是吗？来庇护你，或者如果你愿意的话，找个罪犯——就像你可以把罪犯送到澳大利亚去，给你留下大笔财富。但这确实——我的意思是，这有点说明问题，这么多情节都围绕着一个饥饿、快要饿死的孩子，然后被神奇地收养，带入了资产阶级的世界。我想资产阶级是硬币的另一面。所以想必他们正在以某种方式变得富有。我的意思是，你知道，我觉得即使你看看维多利亚时期的普通
middle class family in the Victorian period, they have extraordinarily little compared to what we expect to have today. They never waste food. If you look at the size of the plates they're eating off, they're just slightly bigger than a side plate. Tapas. Yeah, it is. That's how they're eating um but they're doing better they're definitely doing definitely doing better and so far as we could tell if you look at kind of economic growth and wage growth in the 19th century it seems to suggest that the economy is getting richer and wages are improving but not as much as the economy is
中产阶级家庭，与我们今天所期望的相比，他们的物资极其匮乏。他们从不浪费食物。如果你看看他们吃饭的盘子的大小，它们只比小菜盘稍微大一点。塔帕斯小吃。对，确实如此。这就是他们的饮食方式。嗯，但他们过得更好了，他们绝对过得更好了。据我们所知，如果你看一下19世纪的经济增长和工资增长，它似乎表明经济正在变得更加富裕，工资也在提高，但增长幅度并没有经济增长那么大。
growing so that does suggest that those at the top element the top echelons of society are enjoying more of the profits that are being made than working people okay well this is a question that that dominic i'm amazed dominic hasn't brought up as as our leading left-wing historian um and it's a question from diogo morgado who asked could marxism have arisen without the industrial revolution concepts like class struggle don't necessarily require industrialization the proletariat is a 19th century concept is it not so actually quite a lot of the isms that emerge over the course of the 19th century presumably you know we trace them back to the French revolution but we could
这确实表明，处于顶层的人——社会最高阶层——比劳动人民享有了更多的利润。好吧，这是一个问题——多米尼克，我很惊讶多米尼克没有把这个提出来，作为我们领先的左翼历史学家。这是来自迪奥戈·莫尔加多（Diogo Morgado）的一个问题，他问：如果没有工业革命，马克思主义会诞生吗？诸如阶级斗争之类概念并不一定需要工业化。无产阶级是一个19世纪的概念，不是吗？所以实际上，在19世纪进程中涌现出的相当多的“主义”，想必——你知道，我们可以把它们追溯到法国大革命，但我们也可以
equally trace them back to the industrial revolution would that be right oh I couldn't agree more i i absolutely agree with our interpretation so we have tended to look at movements like the rise of chartism in the british case but all across these all across europe we have tended to look at these movements as having been born out of inequality poverty unfairness and that is all true of course there was poverty and there's a lot of unfairness but it's very difficult to see how 18th century Britain could have sustained mass working class political movements although there were a lot of really poor working people in the 18th century they couldn't group themselves together around a common cause and they couldn't agitate effectively. They didn't have the
同样把它们追溯到工业革命，这样说对吗？哦，我完全赞同，我绝对赞同我们的解释。因此，我们往往将诸如英国宪章运动的兴起之类的运动——但在全欧洲各地都是如此——我们往往认为这些运动是孕育于不平等、贫困和不公正之中的。当然，这都是真的，当时确实存在贫困和许多不公正现象。但很难看出18世纪的英国怎么可能维持大规模的工人阶级政治运动。尽管18世纪有许多非常贫穷的劳动人民，但他们无法围绕共同的事业团结在一起，也无法有效地进行煽动。他们没有
resources, the mechanisms, the education, the literacy, the skills that would be necessary to make a powerful intervention, a political intervention. And one of the really interesting stories of the 19th century is working class people start to organize themselves they view themselves as being important and significant they learn how to coalesce around political causes they learn how to take political action they take really effective political action mass rallies and published newspapers and political manifestos and charters it's all born i mean it's born out of progress and i i would love to suggest that we could turn around that this is kind of born out of desperation and actually view it as what it is it's only relatively it's a relatively advanced and privileged working class or kind of working people who have the resources to articulate their message
实现强有力干预——政治干预——所必需的资源、机制、教育、识字率和技能。19世纪真正有趣的故事之一是，工人阶级开始组织起来，他们认为自己很重要、很有意义，他们学会了围绕政治事业联合起来，学会了采取政治行动。他们采取了非常有效的政治行动——大规模集会、出版报纸、发表政治宣言和宪章。这一切都诞生于——我的意思是，它诞生于进步之中。我很乐意提出我们可以扭转这种观点，即这并非诞生于绝望之中，而是真正视其为本来面目：只有相对而言——一个相对先进且享有特权的工人阶级，或者说劳动人民，才拥有表达其诉求的资源。
and I think it's no accident that it is in 19th century Britain where the industrial revolution is happening that you get a lot of working people starting to articulate a message and that that develops and grows all through the 19th century spreads across to other parts of Europe as other parts of Europe start to industrialize as well. Well, obviously, Marx and Engels, I mean, they're writing about Manchester a lot, aren't they? I mean, they're absolutely, you know, Marxism is completely overshadowed by that experience, isn't it? Do you not think, Tom? I mean, you're going to say it's all about Christianity, I know, so let's not even go there. Well, Marxism, obviously, of course it's Christianity. But what I was actually going to ask was, um 1848 the year of revolutions across continental
我认为这绝非偶然，正是在工业革命发生、19世纪的英国，你会发现许多劳动人民开始表达诉求，并且这一诉求在整个19世纪不断发展壮大，并随着欧洲其他地区开始工业化而蔓延到欧洲其他地区。显而易见，马克思和恩格斯——我是说，他们写了大量关于曼彻斯特的文章，不是吗？我的意思是，绝对如此——你知道，马克思主义完全被那种经历所掩盖了，不是吗？难道你不这么认为吗，汤姆？我的意思是，你会说这完全是关于基督教的，我知道，所以我们甚至不要去探讨那个。好吧，马克思主义，显而易见，当然它是基督教的。但我真正想问的是，嗯，
europe britain doesn't have a revolution even though there's this kind of great chartist demonstration meets at kennington and everything um why do you think that is do you think that you reach a certain plateau of of wealth across society and then actually it's less likely you're going to have a revolution. I don't know. I can't answer why we don't really have anything similar to what's, you know, we don't really have an 1848 revolution like a lot of Europe does. But I mean, I suppose, I mean, in the big macro, you know, kind of stepping back and, you know, looking at things from a bit of a distance, Britain has been different from a lot of continental
1848年，欧洲大陆革命爆发之年，英国并没有爆发革命，尽管在肯宁顿等地有这种声势浩大的宪章运动游行等等。你认为这是为什么？你认为当社会的财富达到某个平台期时，爆发革命的可能性反而会变小吗？我不知道。我无法回答为什么我们没有发生任何类似的情况，你知道，我们并没有像欧洲许多国家那样经历1848年革命。但我的意思是，我想，在大宏观的层面上——你知道，退一步讲，从某种距离来看事情——英国与欧洲大陆的许多国家有很大不同，
Europe for quite a long time, you know, and I think, again, this comes back, you know, it really was quite different by the 18th century, it was already looking quite different by the early 19th century, it's really changed beyond all recognition. Many of these European nations have not really, you know know they're just embarking they're only they've really had an industrial revolution by 1848 so they're just they're just different kinds of nations really with different political setups with different economic setups and with very different issues um that they just make kind of that kind of cross comparison quite difficult to to make.
相当长的一段时间以来都是如此，你知道，而且我认为，这再次归结于——到18世纪时它确实已经很不相同了，到19世纪初时它看起来已经很不相同了，它真的发生了脱胎换骨的变化。其中许多欧洲国家并没有真正地——你知道，它们才刚刚开始起步，到1848年时它们甚至还没有真正经历过工业革命。所以它们只是不同类型的国家，拥有不同的政治体制、不同的经济体制以及非常不同的问题，这使得这种跨国比较变得相当困难。
What do you make, Emma? We're reaching the end. We had a couple of questions about the legacy of the Industrial Revolution. So we had a really interesting one from Jack Fittles, who, for a Dickensian surname, I have to say. He said, he asks about the London Olympics and so on. And he said, you know, we romanticise the Industrial Revolution. How much of it is tied up with the story that Britain tells about its progress, its own?
你怎么看，埃玛？我们快要结束了。我们收到了几个关于工业革命遗产的问题。所以我们收到了杰克·菲特勒斯（Jack Fittles）提出的一个非常有趣的问题，不得不说，他有一个很狄更斯式的姓氏。他说，他问到了伦敦奥运会等等。他说，你知道，我们把工业革命浪漫化了。这其中有多少与英国讲述其自身进步的故事紧密相连？
And it's also, what's so interesting is asking that question after you've just talked about Britain being, I mean, you have slightly given a British exceptionalist answer to the last question. So, I mean, do you think the revolution is is it is it still central to the way that britain views itself and britain's sense of its own you know its own exceptional history unique destiny and all that sort of thing do you think oh that's a lovely question um what i think that's really interesting well i think there are two things there's a number of things i mean i think there are things that we like to have in our understand in our history of the industrial revolution things that get left out so i think there's two things. There's a number of things. I mean, I think there are things that we like to have in our history of the Industrial Revolution, things that get left out. So I think there's been a lot of attempt for a long time to kind of put empire and slavery in.
而且同样有趣的是，在刚刚讨论了英国是——我的意思是，你在上一个问题中稍微给出了一个英国例外论的答案之后，再提出这个问题。所以，我的意思是，你认为这场革命——它是否仍然是英国看待自身的方式、英国对自身——你知道，自身的例外历史、独特的命运以及诸如此类事情的感知——的核心？你认为……哦，这是一个可爱的问题。嗯，我认为这真的很有趣。好吧，我认为有两点——有很多事情。我的意思是，我认为有些事情是我们希望保留在我们的工业革命历史理解中的，而有些事情则被遗漏了。所以我认为有两点。有很多事情。我的意思是，我认为有些事情是我们希望保留在我们的工业革命历史中的，而有些事情则被遗漏了。所以我认为，很长一段时间以来，人们一直在试图把帝国和奴役的历史涵盖进来。
And it's never really quite taken off. And we've really always been much more comfortable thinking about Protestant worth ethics and technology and inventions. I do think there's a big resource story. We needed to get our raw materials, our resources from somewhere. And actually that does lead us out back to empire and it leads us out to warfare. So I'd love to bring that in
但这从未真正流行起来。我们总是更愿意去思考新教伦理、技术和发明。我确实认为这是一个庞大的资源故事。我们需要从某个地方获取原材料和资源。而这实际上确实把我们引回了帝国，把我们引向了战争。所以我很想把这一点引入进来，
and make that much more part of the story. I mean, and historians, academic historians are definitely always saying, look, I think we need to consider this. But I don't think that reaches the um well london olympic ceremony that kind of um that doesn't make it into things like that i think that is fantastically interesting i love that ceremony i've been looking at again recently for reasons of my own um such an interesting interpretation of our national past and of course the i love the when it came out i couldn't believe
并使其成为故事的更多组成部分。我的意思是，历史学家、学院派历史学家肯定一直在说：“听着，我认为我们需要考虑这一点。”但我认为这并没有触及——嗯，伦敦奥运会的开幕式，那种——嗯，它并没有进入那样的事情中。我认为那真是极其有趣。我很喜欢那个仪式，由于我自己的原因，我最近一直在重新观看它。那是对我们民族过去以及当然是工业革命的一种非常有趣的解读。我喜欢——当它刚推出时，我简直不敢相信，
it you know seeing it for the first time but oh my god this is what i do this is all the industrial revolution look at that what i think is also really surprised by that emma were you surprised because i was really surprised i mean i shouldn't have been and i but i just didn't know what our i i wasn't very familiar actually with the olympic opening ceremony so i didn't really quite know what it was going to be um but everybody said look watch it and i think david put it on and said yeah that's my husband they we we should watch this i'm like okay let's watch it um and there it was my work suddenly all in front of my eyes um but anyway that's by the by what was what i love about it is is it does kind of capture how we view well our past but also the industrial revolution and it's not entirely i
你知道，第一次看到它时，天哪，这就是我所研究的。这就是工业革命的一切，看看那个。我也对那场开幕式感到非常惊讶，埃玛，你当时感到惊讶吗？因为我真的很惊讶——我是说，我不应该感到惊讶，但我只是不知道我们的——我其实对奥运会开幕式不是很熟悉，所以我真的不太清楚它会是什么样的。但每个人都说：“去看看吧。”我想大卫把它放出来说：“是的，我是说我丈夫，我们应该看一下这个。”我说：“好吧，让我们看看吧。”然后它就出现了，我的工作突然呈现在我的眼前……不管怎样，暂且不谈这个。我喜欢它的地方在于，它确实捕捉到了我们如何看待我们的过去以及工业革命，而且它并不完全是——
mean it's got that kind of green fields pleasant green fields then the dark and the dark and the smoke the tikensian industrial revolution and it's not entirely celebratory um i mean it's there and i love the fact that it's there because it is so important but if you look at the faces of the workers as they're kind of doing their kind of simulations of their working they've all got sad faces and they've got smoke on their face and it's grim and it's not nice you'd like them to be contemplating their rising wages would you exactly exactly and i think that's interesting why why we as britain i mean it came me away from from the Olympics. I think as a nation, we find it very hard to celebrate the Industrial Revolution. We find it very hard not to be ambivalent about it.
我的意思是，它既有那种绿意盎然的田园风光，又有黑暗和浓烟——狄更斯式的工业革命，而且它并不完全是在歌颂。我的意思是，它就在那里，我喜欢它在那里，因为它太重要了。但如果你看看工人们在进行工作模拟时的脸，他们都带着悲伤的表情，脸上带着烟灰，这一切都阴暗而残酷，一点也不美好。你希望他们去思考自己不断上涨的工资吗？正是如此，正是如此。我认为这很有趣，为什么我们作为英国人——这把我的思绪从奥运会上拉了回来。我认为作为一个国家，我们发现很难去赞美工业革命。我们发现很难不对它抱有矛盾的心情。
So there is this pride in it, but there's also this ambivalence about it that we have. And it's very interesting when you look at other nations talking about their process of industrialisation. When they start to industrialise, they're just thrilled. It's amazing. It's wonderful it's the best thing that ever happened and we have so much chest beating that goes on about whether it was good and whether it was bad presumably because we're the first and so it's much more of a trauma for us we have we have no way of comparing and is i mean it's been a kind
所以，其中既有自豪感，但我们对它也有这种矛盾的情感。当你看到其他国家谈论他们的工业化进程时，情况非常有趣。当他们开始工业化时，他们只是欣喜若狂。这太棒了，太美妙了，这是发生过的最好的事情。而我们却一直在为它究竟是好是坏而捶胸顿足，大概是因为我们是第一个经历者，所以这对我们来说更像是一种创伤。我们没有办法进行比较，而且——我的意思是，这是一种常青的——
of abiding it was a kind of an abiding critique under the Thatcher government, wasn't it? That we've basically, industrialists become very successful and then they go off and study useless things like classics and build country homes and things. And we de-industrialise. So do you think that, I mean, there have been costs for being the first industrialist? Definitely. And I mean, it's why it's good to go back to people like dickens i mean he is part of our cultural heritage he's part of our dna um we it's very hard if you're raised on that kind of interpretation of your history which we kind of are whether we like it or not
这在撒切尔政府统治时期是一种常青的批判，不是吗？即我们基本上是这样的：实业家变得非常成功，然后他们去研究诸如古典学之类无用的东西，去建造乡间别墅等等，然后我们去工业化了。所以你认为——我的意思是，成为第一批实业家也是有代价的吗？当然。我的意思是，这就是为什么回顾像狄更斯这样的人是件好事——我的意思是，他是我们文化遗产的一部分，他是我们DNA的一部分。如果你从小接受那种对历史的解释——无论我们喜欢与否，我们多多少少都接受了这种教育——
it's quite hard then um as mature adults in our 30s 40ss or 50s to say, oh, no, it was great. I mean, it just has become part of our DNA, part of our narrative. And it's very hard for all of us to separate from it. We've got one last question, which I know you will enjoy, from Imagining History. And Imagining History says, why is the Industrial Revolution so interesting, but was so boring to learn about at school? What's all that about? And he's not wrong, actually so boring to learn about at school. What's all that about? And he's not wrong, actually.
那么作为30多岁、40多岁或50多岁的成年人，很难再去说：“哦，不，它太棒了。”我的意思是，它已经成为我们DNA的一部分，我们叙事的一部分。我们所有人都很难从中剥离出来。我们还有一个最后的问题，我知道你会喜欢，来自“想象历史”（Imagining History）。“想象历史”说：“为什么工业革命如此有趣，但在学校里学起来却那么枯燥？这到底是怎么回事？”他其实没说错，在学校里学起来确实那么枯燥。这到底是怎么回事？他其实没说错。
It is quite boring at school. I hated the Industrial Revolution. What is that about, Emma? Are we teaching it wrong? It's so interesting. I know. And it was so boring at school, wasn't it? I mean, gosh.
在学校里确实挺枯燥的。我讨厌工业革命。这究竟是怎么回事，埃玛？是我们教得不对吗？它明明那么有趣。我懂的。而且在学校里学起来太枯燥了，不是吗？天哪。
I couldn't agree more. What were they doing in the 70s and the 80s with the industrial revolution in schools yeah i just remember that's still boring well i don't know i mean i think everything they do at school they do much more interestingly now and i love the way they teach history in schools um nowadays i mean i think i think almost a lot of the history i taught was really boring not just the industrial i think most of the history was really boring. And I love the way they teach history in schools now and they encourage people, you know, they teach about the First World War. And then they get the students to read some letters of somebody who was in the trenches and to think what it was like to have been in the trenches, which is the bit that we didn't do in our day.
我不能再赞同了。70年代和80年代的学校里对工业革命到底在搞什么鬼啊？是的，我只记得那依然很枯燥。好吧，我不知道——我的意思是，我认为他们在学校里做的所有事情现在都变得有趣得多了，我喜欢他们现在在学校里教历史的方式。如今——我的意思是，我认为我以前学过的很多历史真的很枯燥，不仅是工业革命，我觉得大部分历史都很枯燥。而我喜欢现在他们在学校里教历史的方式，他们鼓励人们——你知道，他们会讲第一次世界大战。然后他们让学生阅读某个在战壕里的人写的一些信件，去体会身处战壕是什么感觉，这就是我们那个年代没有做过的内容。
But now how do they teach the industrial revolution do you know well i mean some of them teach the industrial revolution with liberty's dawn which is amazing that's yeah they've got the book tom yeah they've got well and i've seen lesson plans where they give um their students an extract of an autobiography and say let's think about the industrial revolution from this perspective um so i mean it's humanized it's humanized and i guess it's what's happened all through the teaching of history in schools which was very top down there's a lot of humanizing all and i think it's wonderful what they do so it's not just waves of inventions which i know not anymore i think the trick is for imagining history i think the trick
但现在他们是怎么教工业革命的呢，你知道吗？嗯，我的意思是，有些人用《自由的曙光》来教工业革命，这太棒了。对，他们有那本书，汤姆，对，他们有——而且我看到过一些教案，他们给学生一篇自传的节选，然后说：让我们从这个角度来思考工业革命。嗯，所以我的意思是，它是人性化的，它是人性化的，我想这也是学校历史教学中一直以来的变化，以前那是相当自上而下的，现在有很多将历史人性化的内容，我觉得他们做得很棒。所以它不只是发明浪潮，我知道现在不再是这样了。我想想象历史的秘诀，我想秘诀
is to go back to school because schools nowadays are very different places and they're doing a much better job just amazing teachers doing just a fantastic job of making it um lively and interesting so that's a brilliant note on which as are the academics um yeah as are the as is the president of the royal Historical Society. Emma, thank you so much for coming on the programme. Nobody ever again will have the right to say the Industrial Revolution is boring because you've comprehensively proved it isn't. Emma's book is Liberty's Dawn, if you're interested.
是重返学校，因为现在的学校是非常不同的地方，他们做得很棒，出色的老师们把历史变得生动有趣，这是一段精彩的结束语，正如学者们所做的那样——是的，正如皇家历史学会会长所做的那样。埃玛，非常感谢您来到我们的节目。以后再也没有人有资格说工业革命是枯燥的了，因为你已经全面地证明了它并非如此。如果你感兴趣的话，埃玛的书是《自由的曙光》。
And if you're not interested, it's still at Liberty's Dawn. So it's goodbye anyway. Thank you, Emma. Goodbye, everybody. Bye-bye. Thank you. Bye. you Emma goodbye everybody bye-bye thank you bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod dot com that's rest is history pod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你不感兴趣，它依然叫《自由的曙光》。总之，节目就要结束了。谢谢你，埃玛。大家再见。拜拜。谢谢。再见。谢谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。